the techniques always look very simple
so look if i go like this this is outer
deltoid
this is the outer deltoid right now okay
and strong again we just keep
it's going to just keep pushing that
thing
and you can't go again either you go yen
so you have to be able to figure this
out
so we're going to go forward this time
because you're getting away with
all this stuff this is out this is yin
i can't do that
let me just go forward okay
when i go forward i have to get my
finger even when i go backwards this
technique is shared not sure
techniques on the other side
so your your culture projection boom
this part you're just going to do it
straight let's give you a little tougher
on routine
[Music]
there has to be a way to go around that
energy
okay this if you don't accept that then
you don't buy a jiu-jitsu okay
what you guys are doing instead is
creating different angles
like that do you see
so you go i'm going to go around it like
this this is not mechanically sound
and this is not in his center do you see
not till you get back down but right
here it's not
it's not controlling so we'll go slow
so that's what his group's doing and i
have to figure
you're going to feel where you you're
pushing back on him
so i can feel do you feel that i'm
exaggerating i'm trying to lift inside
his hand
that means don't do that okay so i'm
gonna go around it
by bringing my elbow in elbow in
you see okay and now don't push here
you see that that that's pressure
go around go around that go around that
keep relaxing and now you're on the
other side
so instead of these external kind of
giant things where you don't have his
center
i don't have a center don't have a
center now i have the center okay
instead right from the get-go boom
so it's just a basic thing don't push on
that
go around it like water
[Music]
your attention is going to make you
stuck so you have to relax
so your body goes around it
you have to let him go forward otherwise
you're stopping and you're stopping him
that means you're stuck
so you have to want him to go forward so
he goes underneath it
so
okay so just because i have a yielding
footwork this does not do that other
stuff
okay this still keeps that edema spirit
okay then the second thing is not here
you're not pushing him back
you're it's a cocky projection so
wherever you're touching
don't get the external level so the
yield
boom the yield
that's the modern
[Music]
it's
so different do the heel but it's still
straight in
still straight in your heart
[Music]
so
okay so i'm going to put two techniques
together
so that i work on transition
without losing position so if i go like
this
this is a whole new thing okay so
whoa boom see how i'm gonna go
he's gonna go he's gonna go right into
it
all in the box don't let him out of full
check
so boom off balance
boom tilt
that's your skill is how not to lose
kazushi transition
is about transitioning
not transitioning technique
[Music]
positioning
okay the nice part about this
this kazushi girl is you see how i'm
still i'm still
in him okay it has this temptation to
unwind everything and this is where you
guys lose him he's just a
guy i'm not in his center in other words
okay
so when you do that technique so you
guys unwind this and now you're going
right
right from here remember two points of
contact so
unwind in his center the two
arms are working together
[Music]
don't just abandon the arm and go for
his head
and arms dead okay
[Music]
thank you